foreign
[Music]
what's happening back there
I don't know um
I was asleep
I know I came in like 20 minutes before
the show started because I was like Hey
probably about time to start uh you know
getting ready for the show and he's like
yeah huh and I was like yes I'm just
trying to wake up right now I'm just uh
so he's I'm drinking too he's trying to
wake up and I'm like getting some coffee
or something yeah
yeah actually I woke up earlier than
that because I think I woke up about 3
30. we're like old people man we're
getting to bed in like 10.
well I have to I can't stay away any
longer gotta go to bed man it's nine
o'clock yeah once it's like 9 30. well
it wouldn't be like that like over the
weekend like we stay up late because you
know I don't have to get up at [__]
at the ass crack him down right if I
didn't have to get up at the ass crack
of dawn then I would go to bed that
early yeah and we don't even know who
Don is who the hell is Don and her ass
crack
if we knew who she was then yeah
I don't know
oh my God but uh no so I go to sleep
with her you know what I mean
and we wake up around the same time I
mean for a while he was just like I'm
not going to sleep at 10 o'clock at
night that's lame and he would like
either put on his headphones or he'd go
into me he didn't even like watch watch
TV or something so I could sleep but
yeah lately like last few weeks he's
like [__] I'm just like [__]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and then I ended up waking up
just naturally like 4 30 or 5. yeah I do
too I don't even need an alarm clock
yeah I've never overslept I think the
most I've ever slept was like 20 minutes
yeah it's like oh man man see the sun
coming up and everything like oh I have
a big day
remember those [__]
yeah cover all wearing [__] hey
it's time to get up yeah the deer are
getting getting up soon for my dad I
know right yeah we gotta get in a tree
stand before before the [__] sun
comes up
I don't like it and I especially don't
like having to like drive all that way
because the sun is like always right in
my face like the whole way because I
have to drive east the whole entire way
to go to work yeah Zack says it's weird
with me sometimes I'm asleep by 10 other
days I'm gonna sleep till 3am I hate it
my best wake up time is six or seven
earlier later than that and the day
feels way too long or way too short yeah
yeah
murder Hornet says be back later at Taco
Bell okay
all right so this this episode which is
season six I believe is episode two
and we actually watched this we would
normally watch them on Sunday nights but
we actually watched it on Saturday night
after we watched the Zam Shazam
so
um I have to say that I was a little bit
we were both a little bit inebriated
when we watched this I remember it I
like I remember what happened but it's
like I'm reading my notes back today and
I'm like cracking myself up yeah because
like
I deliberately I was like oh this should
be super funny like reading these notes
back again because I was like kind of
drunk when I wrote him down is it just
one page no it's two it's two pages
front and back say like that and it's
like at least I'm I'm proud of myself
they actually are like pretty coherent
and I remember like what they refer to I
remember we were sitting there watching
she started busting up laughing while
she was writing it was a what
yeah
I was like yeah I don't even know what
I'm talking about half the time yeah I
mean you guys know yeah but so okay so
the thing about this remember I said
everywhere even like on IMDb on
Wikipedia on
um like some other things that are
referring to it like on YouTube and
stuff like that like all of the they all
refer to it as well to Hell which to be
fair does make more sense but then when
we watched the actual episode the actual
title card on there says the Well from
hell yeah which again doesn't really
make it I mean it doesn't really make a
difference but I'm just like wondering
why
uh you know why that is
but on the disc it's on the disk that we
own it says the welcome Mill now I
actually did watch right before the show
I found there's a paranormal
investigation group that you know worked
on this called goners
um you know which stands for what the
hell does that stand for Ghosts of New
England research Society yeah that's
right honors so and they had done like a
15 16 minute YouTube uh you know video
about this investigation so they
mentioned a couple things that they
hadn't that they didn't mention on the
show so I thought that was uh kind of
interesting
um so yeah so let's talk a little bit
about this
I remembered this one because I
remembered as soon as I saw the the
photo on IMDb of the girl with the the
feather and the sage like with the
blonde curly hair and everything I was
like oh yeah I remember that one that's
the voodoo girl right that like caused
all the trouble
so I guess this took place in
Connecticut like in Cromwell Connecticut
which I guess is like a little village
up there I don't know I've never been to
Connecticut
now they start out at the beginning like
they just do like a little bit of a
thing like in the early 1960s so I guess
our main protagonist like the guy that
we're gonna be following is named Mark
corvo and I guess he grew up in this
house now they said on a haunting that
it was 1962.
but um when I was watching the the
goners thing about the investigation
they said that his parents actually
moved in there in 1959 and one thing
that he said was really interesting that
I don't think they mentioned on The
Haunting show was that when the parents
moved in in 1959 because the house is
old it was built in like the 1740s
um they were like they when they were
digging um a septic system in the
backyard they found a bunch of uh like
flat headstones back there like so I
guess there have been like a family
Cemetery at some point because the house
was built by like a family and it you
know the family and there's another
family that they had married into and
they had like lived there for a really
long time but I thought that was kind of
interesting and I don't know why they
didn't mention that
on haunting because that would have been
really neat like you know what I mean
like finding finding gravestones when
you're [__] digging a septic tank
um but pretty much all they said from
1962 was that Mark when he was a kid
um was what they would consider an
empath I guess uh you know he
sleepwalking he had super vivid dreams
and I guess and I don't remember if they
mentioned this on a haunting either but
the guy mentioned it on the goners video
that um there had been some minor
paranormal activity in the house when
Mark was a kid like when the parents
were there as well but nothing
major it was just like Little Footsteps
and that kind of [__] like nothing crazy
so then we jump ahead
like 50 years or something like that to
I think it it started taking place in
like 2011.
so I guess Mark's parents have died and
they have left him the childhood home
so he goes back and he still has like a
lot of fond memories of growing up there
and so he's going to uh fix it up and
start renting it out like to tenants you
know I mean because it's I saw the
actual house they didn't use the actual
house on a haunting obviously but on the
goners investigation video they showed
the actual house
um and it's it's a good size it's like
pretty big
so he decides he's gonna like rent it
out and like I said he said that he had
seen like minor Paranormal Activity
there ever since he was a kid but it
wasn't any big deal and he was kind of
used to it so he just kind of like
ignored it because it was nothing major
so um you know so he would hear like
footsteps it's like occasionally like
doors would open and close by themselves
[__] like that like you know pretty
minor
so he's in there for a month and he's
fixing this stuff up and then he has
like his first tenant whose name is Sean
Angus and he's like a firefighter and I
guess he works you know pretty close by
like to the fire station so he rents a
room there too
and then the second tenant is the one
that causes all the trouble and her name
is Ashley singer and I guess she just
moved to the area and she comes in and
she's kind of one of those like super
new AG sort of people right so she comes
in and she's like oh this is I've sent
something in here bloody black
so there's that so she moves into the
other room now Sean the firefighter is
helping out with the renovations and
while him and Mark are down in the
basement they take the cover of this old
well which I guess like down in the
basement there's a well which presumably
is the well to hell or the Well from
hell that we're talking about and Mark
said that he remembered it being down
there from his childhood but that he
didn't really think anything about it
like nothing weird had happened in there
or anything like that it was just kind
of there you know so they kind of like
uncover it
now not too long after this Mark is
sleeping in his bed and he starts
hearing like weird noises like weird
banging sounds like the pipes hissing or
something that sounds like that and
maybe footsteps is like it sounded
pretty much like footsteps and he also
said that Sean the other tenant also
complained about the same kind of noises
he's like that he didn't really know
what that was
and so Ashley uh also thinks something
is up in the house and there's kind of a
part where the chandelier like in one of
the rooms is kind of like moving around
by itself and then a drawer in her room
like opens and closes by itself like
that I think it was like the nightstand
drawer like opened up and then closed
did they see it open or they just they
found it open
well it opened and then it slammed okay
so they didn't find it open so I'm
presuming that she saw it or Mark saw it
like it opened by itself and then closed
again
and also here's footsteps so she tells
Mark about all of this and um you know
he's like well whatever it's just like
an old house like we've had weird [__]
like that happen ever since I was a kid
so he doesn't really take it all that
serious because it doesn't seem like
that big a deal you know what I mean
like it's not hurting anybody
now a few weeks after this I thought
this was kind of funny
Mark starts he's out like in the garden
or whatever working and he starts
smelling smoke and sees smoke coming out
of Ashley's window like of her room and
so he thinks as you would that the house
is on fire so he runs up there like
panicking like oh my God Ashley like let
me know you are right or whatever but it
turns out she was just burning sage up
there I'm like holy [__] like how much
Sage was that [__] burning in that room
where he like where it's like you know
smoke is like billowing out of the
[__] window and he thought it was on
fire Jesus Christ
but yeah so uh she wasn't [__] around
with this age I guess she was like
burning a whole bunch of it
she's like yeah I'm doing a cleansing so
she's got like the feather and all that
and uh Mark's kind of weirded out by
this
um but he's like well you know just
don't burn the house down okay okay
you know so there's that
now a few days after that
um I thought this was kind of strange
too so like Ashley is gonna go to New
Orleans right and she has a friend of
hers what I couldn't figure out what
they said her name was Sandra satra
something like that
so she has this friend come and stay in
the room like while she's in New Orleans
which I was like okay I don't know I
just thought that was kind of weird like
especially if you're living in someone
else's house they're like hey I'm gonna
have this random stranger like come and
live in my room while I'm gone how about
that I don't know I just thought that
was kind of strange but yeah so she has
so this girl comes and like lives in
there while Ashley is in New Orleans
now Sandra or whatever the [__] her name
is
um she's sleeping in the bed one night
and I guess like the sheets start
pulling off like the way they showed it
it was just like the sheets were kind of
like slowly slowly slowly and then
whipped off like really quick like that
like because she kept being like what
the [__] like I'm like pulling him back
up and they kept like scooching down and
then like whipped off you know yeah
[__] with her they're [__] with
her yeah so apparently this was enough
for her to be like yeah I'm out uh so
she gets the [__] out the house she's
like I'm not staying here and that and
then actually she came back like um and
pulled a Karen and she came back like
all [__] pissy and gives the keys
back to Mark like it was his fault or
something like that I'm here you got
some weird [__] going on in this house
I'm not saying in here bloody black
and then this is what I laughed at when
I read my notes back
um because like I said I was kind of
drunk when I wrote these
um I wrote Ashley returns with Millie
vanilliant
and me and Jenna started laughing
I forgot about that yeah she comes back
this second blonde Gob chick with these
uh two hot black guys in the [__]
with with Dragons dreads and Jen's likes
she's gonna be making porn tonight
they're making porn in there they're not
doing paranormal [__] man knock it off
yeah we kind of figured they were
probably making foreign
[Laughter]
yeah I mean yeah girl gotta have a black
man up in there whatever they did kind
of look like they did yeah well that's
why I thought it was funny because it's
just when they showed it because it
looked all um ominous you know like when
she's coming back to walking back down
the street like you know with a posse
yeah and I was just like it's supposed
to be supposed to be they're supposed to
be like Haitian Voodoo pasta that's what
yeah and they're like walking down like
yeah yeah we're gonna do some food but
that's not the way they actually looked
they looked more like uh like Jamaican
mainly vanillis they look like models
yeah that's what I thought that's the
first thing I thought was like yeah so I
said she returns with Millie really yeah
but she'd be walking in front head two
behind her and they're all dressed up in
Black and [__] and they look all serious
yeah I just thought that was really
funny
the interracial Jamaican Voodoo Posse
yeah porn XXX [__] yeah oh they're just
making some Voodoo porn yeah yeah
that's probably a whole subject I was
waiting for it to bust out yeah it's
like where's the food important come on
it was a great setup so this could be a
hell of a scene man
who paid for this yeah they're gonna do
like all kinds who's producing this
scene original right yeah
Zach says you should do a show on Milli
Vanilli yeah I want it I've been I
bought it man I bought into that I
thought that was real I didn't think
that I thought it was real about it I
thought it was real when and when it
turned out that they were lip syncing I
was like
[__] really and I was thinking about
well of course
what are the chances this dude's
actually looking like that could sing
and dance like that and it could sing
like that yeah yeah no too much talent
in one spot
Zach said weren't they German actually I
think they might have been now that you
mention it yeah they might have been
European now you think I thought they
might have been French
were they French Belgian something like
that [__] man now I can't read myself
yeah
it's been so long but yes there was
something weird about the whole thing
and the dudes that were actually singing
it they were black guys they were just
big old fat guy big old fat black guys
yeah
we can't have that can't have that I'm
not sure the Fat Boys no you can't have
that they should have just kept singing
[__] it or notorious b-a-g yeah
but yeah so um so Mark says that when
Ashley came back with Millie Vanilli
that she seemed quote unquote darker
than when she left so yeah she went to
New Orleans and got it awesome
Shenanigans with them black dude she'd
come back darker
telling you man this was just it was too
easy they were just like they were just
like
there's a set and everything yeah
for for [__] with dirty minds like
yeah yeah came back
hair braided in cornrows and [__]
well not quite I mean but that would
have been funny if they had done that if
she'd just come back like with all came
back speak in Ebonics yeah or some [__]
yeah yeah they didn't go there because
that might have been slightly offensive
yeah you know what I mean but like
that's what they were talking about
it might have been I don't know because
they the real woman like the real Ashley
woman was not on there so they just had
like the actress yeah
so yeah so Mark is not happy with this
new version of Ashley who has returned
with these two dudes
um so yeah the two friends obviously are
from Haiti so yeah there's some Voodoo
[__] going on yeah and probably also
porn like you said
so um I mean you might as well
so they blessed the house with Voodoo I
guess
um and then Mark says something about I
don't remember because I just wrote this
down and I I think I we were laughing or
making a joke or something like that and
I didn't catch all of it but I don't
know if Ashley told him this or I think
Ashley told him something like well if
you leave the house or if you ever sell
this house then you'll die
right like did she say something like
that yeah and he was just like uh okay
so whatever
yeah if he ever sold the house or if it
left the family like then he would die
so then he's like Ashley starts because
you know how she was doing the whole
thing with the with the sage and
everything she started smudging the
[__] house every day he goes out and
he sees her I've I admit I've never seen
anybody do this but she was quote
unquote blessing the house or smudging
the house with the garden hose
right like she's posing the front of the
house I'm like it doesn't look like
she's blessing the house it just looked
like she's kind of like rinsing the
windows off is what it looks like but I
guess you're trying to get that [__]
over with man she goes I blessed the
whole water supply well that's why I
thought she just blessed the hoe hoes
yeah
yeah it's it's well
it's efficient why not yeah I mean
that's what if you have the power to
bless water man just [__] bless the
whole [__] Supply
[Laughter]
bless all the water on the world yeah I
mean you might as well it's kind of all
connected right so you can just kind of
go whoa it's everything's holy water the
entire water no vampires can go anywhere
now yeah so
I just blessed all the water in the
world you're welcome yeah water's
connected people
I saw
I saw what some Tick Tock video of this
dude from India pissed off that people
were taking too many showers they were
wasting all that water black water is
wasted he didn't know about evaporation
in the water cycle I guess it's just
[__] funny
I mean water doesn't go away when you
use it
it'll come back it comes back it
evaporates
[__] rains and goes into the ocean
and it evaporates and it's a whole cycle
people don't worry about it yeah don't
worry about it it's a whole cycle yeah
but yeah so uh so you didn't come from
here anyway it was [__] comets
[__] during the Earth's creation
and we might get more comments like
hitting all the time and like the water
came from a Kuiper Belt big [__]
Frozen garbage yeah big frozen
confidence yeah
so uh so yeah so I wrote blessing with
hose which I which was another thing
that made me laugh I mean you know like
I said we were kind of drunk when we
watched this but it did have some funny
[__] in it
so after all of this I guess like her
hose blessing did not work
and she's just like oh well the spirits
in this place are just too intense man
and I just can't handle it so um so yeah
so it's too much for her so she has to
move out and Mark said she moved out
really abruptly like she left most of
her [__] Zach had to go investigate the
black guys want to find out where they
came German French so we were both we
were both right I remembered him as
being French and you remember being a
German they were German French yeah yeah
they were European that was the funny
thing about it why is that funny because
it sounded like they sounded like
like [__] um it was the voices
sounded like
uh African-American guys singing yeah
they weren't well because it wasn't
their voices when their voices right
they're European guys
and they had some I remember hokey
outfits like
little shorts with shirts with suit
jackets on and yeah like the suit
jackets had kind of like big shoulder
pads yeah Red Hats almost like pilgrims
hats and little buckles shoes with
buckles and [__] and socks I don't
remember the buckle shoes I thought they
had but I mean yeah I'm not saying
you're wrong yeah I remember him kind of
looking like pilgrims wearing shorts
I do remember the short the shorts and
the and the suit jacket Ensemble yeah I
do remember that they're pretty boys
they're pretty boys they're like some
weird ass outfits yeah yeah we're just
yeah you know I mean I guess at the time
we didn't think of it as weird because
everybody was wearing stupid [__]
there's weird [__] going all over
do you remember that short-lived Trend
in the 90s where everybody like I guess
it was more like a hip-hop thing where
everybody's like wearing their clothes
uh backwards do you remember that where
everything was like a little bit yeah
yeah yeah wasn't Chris Cross wearing her
pants yeah that's who I was thinking
yeah they were kind of I feel like they
were kind of the Pioneers at that yeah
short-lived Trend yeah maybe they were
the only ones that did it I just
remembered everywhere that's the only
thing I can remember in her videos they
had the pants off yeah they always like
the big bag of clothes that they were
always on backwards they're like hey
that's gonna be our thing we're the
backwards clothes wearing people what
was funny is that in in that era
we actually thought that things like
crisscross were were a naturally
occurring phenomenon like something like
that would actually just naturally
spring up out of the market
you know it didn't really Dawn on us
back then there was a totally
corporate creation totally fictional
yeah and that was like probably some
Executives thing he's like I have an
idea like put put all your clothes on
backwards yeah yeah that'll make you
stand out yeah we're gonna make some uh
what do they call it rap yeah
the kids will love it they all like rap
yeah so we'll get some little black kids
we'll uh write a big old song and they
can wear their clothes backwards and
they can jump up and down
we'll make a [__] ton of money they did
it they were right they did right yeah
yeah yeah so they're not so dumb no they
knew that the audience was dumb
that's what Millie Vanilli was all about
they're just Target marketed Oh They'll
love it here a little voice this off
yeah yeah it'll be fine they'll be into
it and they were it worked
for a limited amount of time then came
to Vanilla Ice
and then and that broke that machine you
never really saw any of that [__] again
like I said please watch cool as ice
well don't watch I wouldn't advise
anyone to watch it that movie but I'm
just saying that that to me like
encapsulates that is the most 90s thing
that has ever existed I think that movie
actually destroyed that marketing
technique from the 90s I think probably
man I saw that movie there like oh damn
this [__] is that fake is that
artificial [__] then it just it
crumbled
I just I I got cramps from cringing
through that movie like I cringed the
whole time it was like watching Saban's
Power Rangers but it was Rap by the way
dude yeah yeah
and it's just like and everywhere
Vanilla Ice went everybody was
everywhere everyone else it sounds like
it sounds like a fairy tale for a second
but it's like wherever he went
everybody's like ooh look at that weirdo
or like he's such a badass and it's just
I'm just like oh my God please stop it
what the [__] is going on like in what
universe is this story existing I just
see it he's a rap impersonator
hahaha
I mean
it's something else if you haven't seen
it like I said I watched it I wouldn't
watch it by itself because I I have too
much self-respect for that but um I did
watch the rift tracks version which is
delightful but it even then like I just
[__] cringed the whole time that act
was fake as [__] yeah it was terrible
that destroyed that dude that was so
terrible yeah last I heard he was like
building cabinets or something yeah he
got sucked into that which I mean you
know no shame in that it's like you know
hey you do a tree hey you want a job you
want to be a rapper yeah it sounds like
we got a job for you man you can sing
kind of yeah
there's a song we got written menu to
love it's called Ice Ice Baby
really yeah
come here let's get you a haircut
in that flat top and then what didn't
you have like stuff like carved in yeah
or whatever you can't ride a motorcycle
no no we'll blurred learn we got we
gotta [__] GSXR for you you got to
ride that
yeah it's totally artificial well and he
was supposed to look like this big hard
ass but like all his clothes looked
brand new like it didn't have anything
brand new like it never wore dirt on him
or anything yeah it wasn't anything hard
about that dude no of course not well
that's what I thought was like super
funny nothing Street about that guy at
all
I'm like if he'd walk down the street
like in that [__] get up he'd
probably got his ass it was the yeah he
got his ass kicked yeah
the whole equivalent of like Tiffany
yeah pretty basically remember Tiffany
yeah yeah remember like that yeah
or Debbie Gibson I'm sorry Deborah yeah
sure I think Deborah Gibson had more to
her than than him uh she did yeah she
actually did seem to have a little bit
of challenge yeah
but um but yeah so where was I all right
so uh so Ashley moves out leaves all her
[__] there which you know whatever
because she's too scared to stay there
anymore so Mark is kind of like upset
about this and like you know concerned
for her and blah blah but we don't know
what happened to her
so Sean is still there though the other
tenant and he has also had his
girlfriend Jessica and she has moved in
now Jessica at one point wakes up and
sees I rewounded a couple things I'm
like what are what am I looking at like
I couldn't tell what I was looking at I
wasn't that drunk I swear but it's like
I'm just like I'm like what are they
showing me
I wrote sheet monster is that what you
saw it looked like a sheep monster right
it looks like something was underneath
the sheet going like you know what I
mean ghost like a ghost under a sheet I
wrote a monster I don't know if that's
what it could I don't know like the way
they shot it it was just like really
close up maybe they didn't have the good
special effects and they're just like
just blow it up real big and just I
don't know what it was but then a sheet
with something projected on it maybe
because yeah because I'm just sitting
there like for a long time I was like
what am I looking at I couldn't tell
what I was looking at that's a sheet
monster I think so uh Jessica is like
yeah um I I don't think so so she runs
out the [__] house in her pajamas and
gets in the damn car
and uh so I guess like Sean chases after
her but then they have like kind of a
jump scare moment where like apparently
the Sheep monster like Banks against the
car like whack like that she's like and
then like he but then it's of course
Shipyard says he's in West Palm Beach
Florida restoring mansions
yeah that's what I thought I thought
he'd gone into like construction yeah
which you know that's good that's
probably like a more yeah
that's important that's a more noble
person he just got caught up in an
industry yeah it was basically like
K-pop but it was American yeah and they
just were like making instant Stars
and it didn't work for long
they had been doing that I think since
the 70s
because there was a lot of instant stars
that just kind of came and went yeah
piazadora one of them
um thank you Jeffy yeah
it's a little dancing pair look it has a
little lover boy thing on it yeah
[Laughter]
Zach says I have a friend up in Elkhart
who's here is Eminem of all people he
even dresses like him my friend's
awesome but it's still kind of funny
like dresses like Eminem yeah
[__]
although Eminem is a real phenomenon
though
yeah I mean like he he's he's a real
rapper well I mean he's actually like I
said he's actually yeah he's downtown so
uh murder Hornet said little Tom says I
can even beat Vanilla Ice's ass yeah
let's see little town yeah Tom's plan oh
yeah yeah the little time
I'm just I'm so happy that I found that
because it's like that looks exactly
like you
but um they just watered they just
wanted an instant wrapper that could
that could sell to the mainstream so he
was gonna be a white guy
that's what they were gonna do yeah I'm
family friendly I guess yeah he's hard
man he's tough we don't know where he
came from she pulled up on a motorcycle
with a rat with a ridiculous jacket yeah
and short multi-colored leather jackets
yeah it's like and did it have like
Words paint at all I had all kinds of
[__] everything was [__] [__] what
they call Spumoni which is overdone man
I'm always Italian ice cream it's got
all the flavors
yeah it was a little it was a little bit
but yeah
tacky yeah very attacking everything
looked real corporate though anyway
nothing was nothing was do it yourself
yeah it's kind of like after Punk got
popular and then like you'd go and see
like these leather jackets like with
[__] painted all over them and they were
like 300 and stuff like that and you're
like that's not really in the whole
Spirit of the thing is it no but um but
yeah all right so uh so the Sheep
monster like I said seems to like chase
her out the house and like bash into the
side of the car but then I don't know if
that really happened they were just
trying to do a jump scare because really
it's just Sean's t-shirt going like
where are you going like driving to the
middle of the night and you're in your
pajamas or whatever she's like [__] this
[__] I'm like out of here because he
tells her oh you were dreaming and she's
like yeah [__] that no I wasn't she's
like I'm not staying in this house I'm
out so she left uh so Sean actually he
didn't tell her to just [__] off I guess
he moved out too so now Mark just lives
in the house by himself he doesn't have
any tenants anymore
so he decides he's gonna launch his own
investigation because if anything Mark
is a man of action that's for sure
it's the way he said it he didn't say he
was a man of action I said that but it's
like just the way he said it implied
that that's what he wanted that's the
impression that he wanted to give so
yeah so he decides he's gonna do like
some EVP [__]
now while he's looking around in the
house I guess in the basement he finds
an altar in there like with a cross like
some empty bottles on it and a dead bird
so that's like the voodoo [__] so I
guess that that was what Ashley and
Millie Vanilli were doing down in the
basement all that time like doing Voodoo
[__] in the basement and presumably
making the Paranormal Activity worse
actually Millie Vanilli six magic yeah
that's what they're doing down there
yeah
so Mark keeps doing the EVP sessions uh
every night now he plays one back
one of them I'm pretty sure my hearing
is bad you guys
um it sounded like someone was shouting
help right but then there was other ones
that had kind of like overlapping
demonic voices and they played them and
it's like and it's pretty clear that
they
thought that we'd understood what the
[__] it said but I am here to inform you
that I did not understand a single word
of that my hearing's still okay
and then like the way they talked about
it afterward like it it seemed like they
were implying that like we knew what
that said I'm like bro I I don't know
what that said that could be saying
anything yeah that could be saying
um how would you like a fluffy kitten
you know what I mean I don't know but I
couldn't tell what it said
so uh so he decides he's gonna call some
paranormal investigators as I said
before these are called The Ghosts of
New England research Society or goners
for short now the guy that runs it is
named Kurt I can't remember what his
last name is but we kind of here's
another thing that we looked at because
um when they first showed Mark calling
Kurt at the at the goner's office it
looked like the office was like in a
skyscraper
and we were kind of like come on yeah we
were like going damn they're up in the
top of the skyscraper they're like how
much money is this Paranormal Society
making like they have this really Swanky
office like in the downtown skyscraper I
don't think so well they had an
establishing shot that led you to
believe that this is a skyscraper but
then then this in the following sequence
they're talking to him in an office and
and you look out the window and it's the
backyard right so I don't know if that
was intentional that I kind of feel like
it happened most of the time when they
have somebody calling
the paranormal investigators it's always
kind of like they have an office I'm
like I'm pretty sure it's mostly just
out of people's houses
right I would imagine
like yeah if you have an office in your
house you can run your Paranormal
Society out of that yeah our shit's more
advanced man our [__] looks like a damn
Studio waiting rooms the snack rooms and
break rooms and [__] yeah we should
bring your clients over here
doing paranormal [__] paranormal porn
there you go that's our knees we have
all black dudes coming over
I'm gonna be back there producing this
[__] man the director has been sitting
up in the director's chair Jenny's
writing the scripts
we could like that you know what
actually
actually Pioneer a whole sub-genre of
paranormal porn you wouldn't have to pay
any actors because they could be like
invisible ghosts because you're just
like you know they're [__] each other
right
or you could have one person and then
the ghost is [__] bill I'll talk to
Bill ask him see if there's I mean I'm
sure there's already I'm sure somebody's
thought about the market viability of
invisible porn because I'm like that
because you don't have to pay a ghost
I mean well maybe do maybe they get mad
but it's like what are ghosts gonna do
with money nothing so it's like you know
what I mean
I don't know I'm just saying every scene
is like something out of the entity you
just see the girl right that's see
that's what I was thinking yeah that's
what I was thinking except considerably
less violent because that was like that
that was like some raping [__] going on
but you know what I mean so uh so yeah
so we just kind of laughed because we're
like we're pretty sure that this
paranormal uh investigation group
doesn't have an office in a downtown
skyscraper that would that would really
be something unless I'm you know they
inherited money from their family or
something
so they kind of talked a little bit
about the history of the house
so the house was built in I think 1741
and it was built by a guy named William
what was his name Shanny Fanny something
like that
Randy that's right I wrote it down and I
don't think I can't even [__] read it
now but um yeah so and he was like a
slave trader so I guess he had a bunch
of slaves on live slaves in the house
and [__] like that and he was like a sea
captain also
now when they did all these EVPs there
was like all these separate voices on
there like I said they played some of
them and I'm just like you're presuming
that I understand a word out of that it
sounded like Charlie Brown's Mom I just
couldn't tell what they were saying
now so the paranormal team comes to the
house
um and I wrote down including Kristen
the psychic Melanie the tech person and
Pat the something
because I didn't know what Pat did
because I I just I didn't catch that
evidence collector I said maybe
and then of course they go down to the
basement and they see the infamous the
titular well from Hell or well to hell
and you know what they said about that
well
that's a portal baby
so the psychic gets she's down there
kind of like farting around by the well
and she gets kind of physically hit by
some dark energy from Noel so a ghosty
comes like out of the well
and it's supposedly a kid
that like goes into the psychic
I guess which sounds kind of dirty but
let's not go there because it's a kid
yeah so so
the psychic said she felt the ghost like
touching her cheek and her hair and she
said she heard the kid say where's Mama
Mama got sick
so I guess they're presuming that this
little girl was like a slave girl and
her mom got sick and got taken away and
presumably died and they never told the
little girl where her mom went so she's
still like haunting the place like
waiting for her mom to come back so
there's that
so then Kurt and Pat to something
explore the attic and they find some
Voodoo symbols
and one of them starts feeling really
weird like kind of nauseated or whatever
and then the other one I guess they see
like an apparition next to Kurt Like Pat
sees like an apparition next occur in
like a hand like reaching for his
shoulder like that but I guess like Kurt
doesn't see it but because then when he
turns there's like nothing there
so according to the team they say well
this house has you know been a shelter
for lost souls for centuries so like I
said well to hell or well from hell that
seems like a little bit of a misnomer
because these aren't demons or anything
like that it's just like a bunch of
ghosts in the house presumably
um but they said yeah it was probably
like all that Voodoo [__] that Unleashed
this particular Dark Energy so you know
it's all Ashley's fault and and Millie
vanilli's fault
so
um Kurt and this other person the
psychic I guess
tell Mark that it's like well you're
more tuned into the supernatural than
usual and that's why you got all these
EVPs because apparently he had like a
whole bunch of them now one thing they
didn't mention on the show but that like
the guy I get I think it was Kurt
that did the um the goners thing that on
YouTube that I saw he said that they got
a bunch of EVPs and he's like some of
the EVPs were like nice like you know
they were female voices and they were
like say would say like affectionate
things and stuff but then he's like
there were some of them that
he this stood out to me he said one of
them told Mark that he was going to give
him cancer okay and I was like rude well
they said Mark did get cancer like later
on you know what I mean so I don't know
if he's I think he's still alive but I
don't I don't really know because that
video was like 10 years ago or something
like that because this came out in 2013
this show
which was 10 years ago
so yeah um
so basically they're gonna have to like
they're like well you're just gonna have
to deal with all these Spirits uh but
you're gonna need some tools you're
gonna have to do like meditation and
prayers and bloody blah because they
didn't really this was one where they
didn't because usually they're like oh
we're gonna help the spirits cross over
they didn't like say that in this one
they're just like that deal with it yeah
they're good over there
they sorted out I guess well I guess
because the well is there and it's a
portal so it's like well even if you get
rid of these ones like more ones are
gonna be popping through being like hey
what's going on here you guys you know
what I mean like it's like the ghosty
hangout yeah so I guess they're like
don't even bother you're just gonna have
to like deal with it and hope they don't
like Wing a brick at your head well the
hell reminds me of the I was thinking
more along the lines of like art belly
what he had that ongoing story what's
called Mel's hole there's some [__] like
that
are we exploring Bell's hole
some dude
in this [__] property and he's
putting the microphones down there you
hear people screaming in the like oh I
know what you're talking Mel's hole I
think that's what the story is called
because of course they called it
yeah I think that's what it was called
quit sticking you got a microphone up
your ass
drop in the comment sections what it
what it really was I think it was Mel's
hole he like that would be really funny
if he stuck like the microphone up his
ass and it was like demon screams and
stuff the vowels of hell yeah literal
yeah Mel's old Jesus Christ
that's ridiculous
murder horses I remember that episode
yeah and he was playing that he's
playing the recordings here oh and it's
like [__] echoing all these people
screaming
it's Souls of hell
wow [__] yeah wow
it goes all the way down to hell yeah it
does I want to have an expedition I want
to be lowered down in there
I wanted all this money to help him
build this crane and they were gonna
[__] [__] miles and miles of cable
to lower him down there he could
document it why the [__] would you want
to go down there he was lying yeah he
was lying I was saying even if you did
have that yeah I'm not good I'm just
gonna stay over here I'm not going down
in there he wanted to be the first
person to explore it
that was back at the Art Bell man our
Bell is a [__] cool show man
pre-internet
you couldn't check on anything I just
admire his ability to keep a straight
face during all of that stuff like he
didn't like make fun of anybody or see I
wouldn't be able to resist he was a
legend man a radio great
yeah he just kind of like took
everything at face value he was like wow
really you sit there and listen to his
show and you just chill out relax and
[__] drink or smoke a Dube or just
whatever you'd be trying to tune in on
that damn AM station to hear him
broadcaster from the desert
and he'd take you into another world man
it was like you were listening to some
kind of secret transmission
had good guests on and [__] and
everything
yeah first ever I I do remember you
talking about Mel's hole I don't think I
ever heard like solid like yeah Santa
just sent me all kind of links to the
old shows there's people that have
archived all those old shows so if you
ever want to you go back and listen to
commercials and all
and evidently there's not many of the
you know
a lot of this the a lot of the the shows
survived but he didn't record any of
that evidently
you know I mean like he didn't keep an
archive
like not extensive archive but I know
he's crazy he did repeats and [__] but
yeah they're not published he might have
them that might be in his house
but I think his wife died and I think he
dies I don't know who's got all this
stuff
hmm
it's kind of sad well that's why they
don't
um why it's hard to find like old TV
shows like from the 40s and 50s and
stuff like that because they didn't
think to keep it like in particularly
too like when they would do TV shows
live yeah like they didn't really even
if they did keep it they're just like
man then after a while like you know the
studio had burned down or they'd throw
it out or something like that most of
the stuff that's out there at Art Bell
that survived that's in the internet was
recorded by fans on tape
I don't know
somebody's tapping on something out
there the neighbor
it's one of them ghosts man yeah because
we were talking about ghosts in their
game man so they're tapping at us it
came from Mel's hole no hole
didn't do a show about Tom's hole listen
to Jen
[Laughter]
she's got these weird fans you know I
had to walk it yeah it was right there
it was right there yeah yeah
that's right okay you know how you know
how it goes
so yeah so like I said they didn't even
[__] bother
doing exorcisms or doing
cleansing or anything like that they
were just like basically deal with it
[__]
um that's about it there's just like
ghosts all up in this [__] and the house
is old so it's like you just have to you
know live with it
so Mark decides he just starts you know
reading the Bible and all that and um
he's he's like well basically the thing
that you need to do is like don't engage
them so he just kind of starts
concentrating on the renovations and he
said that he was fixing the outside of
the house
like working on the gutters or something
like that ouch I got my [__] ring
caught in my hair and he felt an evil
presence he said
and then he says he's like and I always
think it's like don't antagonize it
don't like think negative thoughts or
anything like that because that like
always makes it worse but
um apparently he got mad at it and he
yells leave me alone
and at this point the ghosts throw him
off the ladder
or he just fell off the ladder um so I
fell off the ladder yeah he's it does
sound more dramatic if like a ghost
pushed you off the ladder then it's just
well I fell yeah and um yeah so I guess
he was like up by the roof like second
or third floor or something like that so
he actually broke his back like he fell
off so the ghost broke his back so it
was ghosts or dicks yeah
okay but they said you broke his back
and they said it was only three weeks
recovery I'm like oh well that's that's
might not have been seriously yeah well
I hope not well yeah because if it's
really bad then you'd be like a [__]
paraplegic so yeah didn't break his
spinal column I guess not yeah but yeah
so the ghost pushed him off the house
and broke his back so [__] but yeah
so but I guess he's still living in the
same house uh or he was as of this show
and he is just basically the the
voiceover said the battle rages on
because all Mark says it's like you
can't let anger uh you know control the
[__] like it makes all the stuff worse
so he's just doing prayer and meditation
and focusing on positive stuff because
Spirits thrive on fear so once he
started doing that like the Paranormal
Activity like lessons significantly but
I guess it's like still around so he's
at home holding down the forward against
the forces of [__] paranormal evil
pretty much yeah yeah he soldiers on
okay
like I said it's good episode don't know
if any of it happened hard to pick it
through there's no way to investigate it
through the story there's not enough not
enough there not enough not enough
evidence it's just a story
yeah if you're interested in a little
bit more material about it they do have
like I said the goners
do have like a 16 minute YouTube video
where they kind of document a little bit
you talked a little bit about their
investigation there and they showed the
real house and like the Mark is in it
and stuff like that so I watched that
before it was kind of interesting and
like I said they did mention some stuff
that they didn't mention on the show
like the stuff about the graveyard like
the graveyard that was in the backyard
that they didn't mention okay so we uh
we refer you to that what's it called
again yeah it's just I think um their
channel is called goners on TV is I
think the name of the channel and then
if you just put in like a haunting well
to hell it should come up because that's
it was Google or uh in YouTube and
YouTube on YouTube like because that was
like one of the first things that came
up when I searched for well to hell they
call it well to Hell everybody calls it
that except for the actual episode I
don't know how that happened because it
says the Well from Hell very clearly
well I've been typo
I don't know that's a hell of a typo
yeah and like I said well to Hell makes
more sense well neither of them makes
sense in the context of the show because
like I said no demons came out or
nothing like that I was just mostly
ghosts some just some of the ghosts were
dicks yeah but they didn't say anything
about demons or nothing although they
did say some of the EVPs were like
demonicy kind of voices but you know
that could have just been like a dude
from a death metal band that died yeah
and he was just contained he was just
continuing the [__]
like in the afterlife all right so is
there anything else on the on the uh
case nope that's about it all right then
that's about it how long you been going
for uh not even an hour not even an hour
okay which is weird because it seemed
like it seems like a lot longer yeah
it's because we're tired but yeah that's
probably why
all right then we'll guess we can shut
it down what's the next show going to be
the next show is Wednesday Wednesday
night yep you should be excited about
this one because we are going to be
talking about somebody recommended this
a long time ago we are going to be
talking about
operation midnight climax which was part
of MK Ultra oh that's the the San
Francisco whorehouse yeah yeah LSD
whorehouse yeah okay yeah it's gonna be
good you know about that yeah so yeah
we're gonna be talking about that we did
a show about MK Ultra but I don't think
that we mentioned operation midnight
climax yeah LSD warhouse whorehouse had
uh hookers and and [__] CIA was they
were doing it out of a CIA
um Safe House
in San Francisco in an upscale area
they got their hands on some hookers and
they had I think it was just one hooker
I'm not sure might have been two and
they were working them through that safe
house
and they were dosing the clients with
LSD
and the CAA guys were watching them
through a two-way mirror recording it
some weird [__] man they're trying to
see if they could
get guys to [__] be real suggestible
and think of brainwash them and how they
could set them up and stuff yeah I don't
know all the details you're going to end
up finding out more than me I just heard
it mentioned a lot yeah MK Ultra stuff
yeah so like I said we did do kind of an
overarching identified the girls right
um yeah as far as I know yeah do we even
know what they look like you were you
able to find any pictures oh I don't
know I haven't seen any pictures okay
but you know I always wondered what they
look like
their asses
oh yeah maybe
that would be something there might not
be any photographs left over them maybe
not yeah maybe not but yeah he was
involved in that [__] that's true
but and they do worse [__] now much
worse they did much worse [__] that was
the that was the lightweight [__] that
they found out about back then they're
doing a lot worse now involving kids
oh so Zach was talking about his his
friend that loves Eminem it's like his
friend my friend who loved Eminem is
actually one of those Italian dudes
who's super pale but I imagine Northern
Indiana being inside the Arctic Circle
doesn't help yeah I mean you know
[__] Eminem
yeah all right so uh hopefully you guys
can drop by and see us Wednesday night
we're gonna talk about some LSD some
hookers yeah some mind control yeah my
control so that should be fun and uh
hopefully you guys enjoyed hearing about
this well from Hell episode of Haunting
and hopefully you guys have a good rest
of your evening and you have a good day
tomorrow and we'll see you guys again on
Wednesday night
good night